the group linked up oh thank you thank
you so much and all of the ocean minded
community that's participated in this
that's one great thing about Artemis is
that it brings together and like-minded
groups if you go outside tonight you're
going to see the Humane Society you're
going to see s4c you can see surfrider
foundation you're going to see a number
of nonprofit groups that all work
together their issues are not always the
same but regardless they teamed up in on
a project like this and they've created
awareness for this issue that's super
important so we want to give a big
things to fill all those people for kind
of collaborating and also say hey in the
future collaborate warm just before we
get started as Justin said something
that reminded me of a joke that we have
an artivist the very first year of the
Artemis film festival a journalist from
the Los Angeles Times actually second
year of the arguments Film Festival a
journalist of the Los Angeles time came
up to me and said I really love this
festival it's the only place you can get
the human rights people and the animal
rights people together in one place and
you don't have to call the cops so it
really is about bringing this very
diverse advocate community that cares
about humanity animals in the
environment and it
there really is no arena where these are
three incredibly separate yet
interdependent communities really have a
chance to come together so we're really
glad that you're all here today and for
everyone make sure that you please pick
up an Artemis magazine on your way out
we're going to be here for the next
three days for showing 41 incredible
films and they're all complimentary to
the community so please do support the
filmmakers support the films and we hope
that you will spend more time with us
over the next three days